um
when was like when did you realize or
like you guys as a crew like that
gangster grills was like
the brand
um like well like i know that like the
early tapes but like what was the one
like like the one that like do you
remember that moment where you were like
it was levels it was a lot i mean
yeah there were levels because
[ __ ] i think about like gangsta girl six
we had like
bone crusher david benner and killer
mike hostin it was like
we wound up seeing nothing but boot like
when 50
when give richard not trying came out we
wound up finding his like bootleg
spot in the tuck in the west end and we
literally saw like get rich or die
trying
walls full and then gangster grill six
walls full so it was almost like
flattering they booted your [ __ ]
100 like it was the most flattering
thing ever we i was
ecstatic um so then there was that level
then there was like
the tia down no the ti meets gangster
girls
uh in the streets was literally the
first
tape that was just one artist you know
before that it was like compilation
it was a mixtape so then it was that
level that we knew okay there's
something
i remember you know them even tell i
remember we went to like make show power
summit that year
and i was thinking about taking more of
my neo soul tape than i was
did get the tip tape and sense and kind
of like
you bugging like the [ __ ] are you
talking about um
that's just how hype i was just on the
automatic like a whole nother series i
had but
right right right then there was um i
can't even imagine you
like talking your [ __ ] over automatic
relaxation
there's some trivia what was the first
gangster girl not the first gangster
girls tape what was the first name
um how was it jim crow laws that was one
and then how the south was one that's
another
yeah the south was one that was that's
when we knew it was like oh
yeah okay yeah you get upset because
from the college day yeah because it was
moving like that was our first soft tape
and then obviously the tip down with the
king
that was a that was a big tape that
started garning some more attention that
was
you couldn't go nowhere especially in
atlanta night that the one that um at
jack and for beats on it yeah that was
the one i had jacket for beats on it
yeah jack and the beats
that's that's still my favorite that's
like peak t.i
emceeing right there he was going crazy
and then
gz um um mr
streets is watching the first gz tape
and i was like
you know jeezy before jeezy was jeezy
gangster girls was gangster girls so
you know it was that tape was like the
first of its kind where it was like it
was an artist that
no one was really familiar with compared
to like
tip tape or bumby tape that came before
that and obviously like
trapper dies like the world changed like
everything was different so
so yeah i would say going up to that
level that was
those couple tapes to figure it out